PERHAPS THINGS NEED TO BE
DECLASSIFIED IN A MORE
TRANSPARENT AND FAST FASHION
THAN THEY ARE.
GUYS, THANKS SO MUCH.
WHAT IS IT LIKE TO BE TARGETED
FOR YOUR POLITICAL BELIEFS BY
THE FULL FORCE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT?
WE'LL ASK THE MAN, DeSOUZA.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US
TONIGHT.
THIS PARDON HAS SET OFF A
FIRESTORM OF FREAKOUTS AMONG
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT.
AND TODAY WE HAD AN ESPECIALLY
BIG FREAKOUT FROM A FORMER OBAMA
U.S. ATTORNEY ON MSNBC THIS
MORNING.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IT CONCERNS ME NOT ONLY IS HE
VIOLATING THE NORMS OF NOT GOING
THROUGH THAT NORMAL PROCESS, BUT
IS HE PAINTING A NARRATIVE THAT
SENSITIZES THE PUBLIC THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS OFTEN UNFAIR TO
PEOPLE.
WHICH I THINK HAS LONG-TERM
DAMAGING CONSEQUENCES TO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
>> THE LEFT HAS FREAKED OUT MORE
OVER MY PARDON THAN MAYBE ANY
OTHER.
I WAS WATCHING SOMETHING ON CNN,
I THINK IT WAS EARLIER TODAY, OR
YESTERDAY, THESE THINGS BECOME A
BLUR, AND THEY WERE SAYING HOW
DANGEROUS IT IS THAT I GOT THIS
PARDON.
AND I WAS THINKING ABOUT IT, AND
IT OCCURRED TO ME, I THINK I
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GETTING AT.
IT'S DANGEROUS TO THEM.
IT'S DANGEROUS TO THEIR
IDEOLOGY, AND DANGEROUS IN A WAY
THAT OTHER PARDONS -- THINK OF
THE CLINTON PARDON OF MARK RICH.
YOU'VE GOT A GUY HERE WHO'S AN
INTERNATIONAL ARMS TRADER AND
POSSIBLY A TAX FRAUD, INVOLVED
IN ALL KINDS OF RACKETS.
BUT HE'S NOT DANGEROUS TO THE
IDEOLOGY AT CNN.
IN FACT, HE HELPS TO SUPPORT
PROGRESSIVE CAUSES, HE GIVES
MONEY TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
I, ON THE OTHER HAND, IS A
NONWHITE IMMIGRANT WHO CAME TO
AMERICA WITH $500 IN MY POCKET.
AND I'VE BEEN EXPOSING THE WHOLE
PROGRESSIVE IDEOLOGY.
SO I'M DANGEROUS IN THAT WAY.
THEY'RE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: JOHN AVALON ON CNN
TODAY WAS, AGAIN, THE MEDIA, THE
DEMOCRATS, THE NEVER-TRUMPERS,
THEY'RE ALL QUESTIONING WHY THIS
OCCURRED.
AND LET'S WATCH.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS?
>> I THINK YOU SEE THIS AS THE
POWER OF THE PRESIDENCY MEANS A
GET OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD.
THIS IS ALSO WHO'S BEEN A
SELF-STYLED CONSERVATIVE
INTELLECTUAL WHO HAS BEEN A
TWITTER TROLL FOR A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME RIGHT NOW, APPEALING TO
ALL THE WORST INSTINCTS AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
>> I'VE NEVER ALLEGED ANY
CONSPIRACY OF ANYONE.
WHAT I'VE DONE IS EXPOSED THE
SORDID HISTORY OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, A HISTORY THAT ACTUALLY
CONTINUES TO THE PRESENT.
I'VE ALSO EXPOSED A LOT ABOUT
OBAMA.
OBAMA WOULD NOT HAVE INDICTED ME
IF I DIDN'T MAKE A FILM THAT
DEEPLY UPSET HIM.
I DIDN'T JUST GO AGAINST HIS
IDEOLOGY, I KIND OF GOT INTO HIS
HEAD.
AND SOMETIMES WHEN I SPEAK ON
CAMPUS, PEOPLE GO, WELL, GEE,
DIN ESH, WHAT MAKES YOU THINK
OBAMA SAW YOUR DUMB MOVIE OR
CARES ABOUT WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY.
THE REASON I THINK THAT IS
BECAUSE HE WAS ATTACKING ME ON
HIS PERSONAL WEBSITE
BARACKOBAMA.COM.
THERE YOU GO.
THIS IS A NARCISSISTIC PRESIDENT
WHO RECRUITED ERIC HOLDER TO
CARRY HIS WATER FOR HIM, TO GO
AFTER ME.
>> Laura: CNN SUBSCRIBED TO THE
LIBERAL IDEOLOGY, DINESH.
THEIR POINT IS PEOPLE LIKE YOU,
AND PEOPLE LIKE ME, WE'RE
ALT-RIGHT.
YOU'RE NOT A CONSERVATIVE AND
YOU'RE NOT WINNING IN THE ARENA
OF IDEAS, YOU'RE ALT-RIGHT, OR
YOU'RE XENOPHOBIC, AND I LOVE IT
WHEN THEY CALL YOU RACIST,
THAT'S ALWAYS FUN.
IT'S A WAY TO AVOID AN ARGUMENT,
A DEBATE.
WE SAW THIS GOING BACK TO
COLLEGE, DINESH AND I WENT TO
DARTMOUTH COLLEGE TOGETHER, WAY
BACK BEFORE THEY CALLED IT
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS.
THEY WERE TRYING TO AVOID THE
FUNDAMENTAL DEBATE ABOUT THE
GREATNESS OF WESTERN
CIVILIZATION, HOW OFF-TRACK THEY
HAVE BEEN ON SO MANY ISSUES, THE
DECLINE OF TRUE INTELLECTUAL
THOUGHT AND DIVERSITY OF
THOUGHT.
THEY DIDN'T WANT THAT DEBATE,
THEY WANT TO SHUT DOWN THE
DEBATE IN LINE WITH, FRANKLY,
WANTING TO SHUT YOU DOWN, OR
THIS SHOW.
>> HERE'S A TINY DETAIL ABOUT MY
CASE THAT'S SO REVEALING.
THIS CLINTON APPOINTEE JUDGE WHO
ADJUDICATED THE CASE, SAYING
THERE'S NO POLITICAL TARGETING
HERE, AS PART OF MY SENTENCE HE
SENTENCES ME TO MANDATORY
PSYCHIATRIC COUNSELING.
LET'S THINK ABOUT THIS FOR A
MINUTE.
WHAT ABOUT MY CASE?
HERE I'VE GIVEN TOO MUCH MONEY,
MY OWN MONEY, TO A CANDIDATE, A
COLLEGE FRIEND OF MINE RUNNING
DAHMER.
I DIDN'T PUT BODIES IN THE
REFRIGERATOR.
WHY DO I NEED PSYCHIATRIC
COUNSELING?
IF NOT THAT IT'S THE PROGRESSIVE
VIEW THAT I'M NOT JUST WRONG,
BUT I'M SOMEHOW CRAZY?
THAT PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH
THEM REQUIRE NOT PERSUASION, BUT
THERAPY.
AND SO THIS IS THE KIND OF
REEDUCATION PROJECT THAT WAS
ATTEMPTED ON ME, AND FINALLY THE
JUDGE BECAME SUPER FRUSTRATED
AND THREW UP HIS HANDS AND
BASICALLY SAID THE REEDUCATION
HAS FAILED, THIS MAN CANNOT BE
PSYCHOLOGICALLY REHABILITATED,
WHICH I TOOK AS A GREAT
COMPLIMENT.
>> Laura: MAYBE THEY SHOULD HAVE
PUT YOU UP ON THE RACK, AND
WATERBOARDED YOU.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN AN ENHANCED
INTERROGATION THEY WOULD HAVE
SUPPORTED ON THE LEFT.
I ALSO WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS
ON COMMENTS MADE TONIGHT BY
STEVE BANNON, FEATURED TONIGHT
ON CNN.
HE SEEMS TO BE REENTERING THE
PUBLIC ARENA, HE'S BEEN OVER
THERE IN ITALY, MAYBE WORKING ON
THAT POPULOUS MOVEMENT OVER
THERE.
HE SAID THIS ABOUT THE MULLER
INVESTIGATION.
>> I'VE BEEN A BIG PROPONENT --
I SAID, DON'T FIRE COMEY.
I'VE SAID, HE'S A COMBAT PLA
REIN.
THAT OUGHT TO PLAY OUT AS IT'S
GOING TO PLAY OUT.
>> I JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
MAKE OF IT.
I WILL SAY THAT ACTUALLY MUELLER
WAS THE HEAD OF THE FBI WHEN MY
CASE FIRST SURFACED.
AND THE CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN TRYING FOR A
WHILE TO GET MY FBI FILE, AND
COULDN'T.
AND THEN FINALLY THEY GOT IT
REDACTED, BUT IN IT, IT
IDENTIFIES ME AS A PROMINENT
CRITIC OF OBAMA.
AND I THINK THAT'S VERY
INTERESTING, BECAUSE WHY IS THAT
IN MY FILE?
IF THIS IS A CASE OF LADY
JUSTICE BEING BLIND,
INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN
VIOLATION, WHY HIGHLIGHT MY
POLITICS.
I THINK IT'S BECAUSE THE MUELLER
FBI IS SIGNALING TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, THE HOLDER JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, HERE IS A GUY WHO'S
ONE OF YOUR POLITICAL ENEMIES,
HERE IS A GUY YOU MAY WANT TO GO
AFTER.
THIS IS WHAT THE LEFT IS DOING
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
THIS IS WHAT MAKES PEOPLE LIKE
ME DANGEROUS TO THEM.
THIS IS WHY I'M NOT AN ORDINARY
CONSERVATIVE, BUT SOMEBODY WHO
ULTIMATELY THEY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE LOCKED UP.
>> Laura: WELL, THEY'VE SEEN,
AND THEY'VE TRIED TO SILENCE
CONSERVATIVES BEFORE.
AGAIN, GOING ALL THE WAY BACK TO
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THEY SHUT DOWN SPEAKERS.
YOU'VE HAD PROBLEMS ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
OBVIOUSLY ANN COULTER, WE'LL
TALK TO HER IN A SHORT WHILE,
SHE'S HAD PROBLEMS.
EVEN BEING ABLE TO SPEAK,
PHYSICALLY BEING ALLOWED TO
SPEAK AND PARTICIPATE.
NOW IN THE OBAMA ERA, DINESH,
THAT WAS USED AS A TACTIC,
INTIMIDATION, FOLLOWING FOX NEWS
REPORTER CHERYL ATKINSON, HER
COMPUTER WAS BROKEN INTO.
THESE ARE INTIMIDATION TACTICS
THAT GO BEYOND THE STUFF THAT
WE'D NORMALLY THINK OF.
WE TALK ABOUT RUSSIA, BUT
THEY'RE ADOPTING THE TACTICS OF
THE OLD SOVIET UNION.
>> THERE'S A DEEP LEVEL OF LYING
AND DECEPTION THAT GOES ON HERE.
YOU KNOW THAT BOTH OBAMA AND
HILLARY WERE THE DISCIPLES OF
SOLYNNSKY.
>> Laura: WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS IT'S MOVING
FARTHER AND FARTHER LEFTWARD?
>> TO ME, THE PARTY IS IN MANY
RESPECTS ROTTEN TO THE CORE.
AND WHAT'S REALLY HOLDING IT UP
IS NOT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ITSELF, BUT BUT ITS OWN WEIGHT
IT WOULD COLLAPSE.
IT'S SUSTAINED BY A KIND OF
OUTSIDE ALLIANCE INVOLVING
PEOPLE IN ACADEMIA, THE LEFT IN
THE MEDIA, AND THE LEFT IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
THE LEFT CONTROLS THESE THREE
MEGAPHONES OF OUR CULTURE, AND
THEY CAN PUT OUT LIES AND
DISINFORMATION AS LONG AS THAT
CONTINUES.
THEY'RE WHAT'S HOLDING UP THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY RIGHT NOW.
THEY'RE THE COVER-UP ARTISTS FOR
THIS PARTY.